ce week end au couvre-feu a été
éprouvant depuis samedi 17h les civils
ne pouvait pas sortir on les avait
prévenus s'ils sortaient on pouvait leur
tirer dessus car ils pouvaient être
considérés comme des ennemis russe ces
saboteurs ses forces au sol qui prépare
à l'arrivée possible des troupes russes
en masse dont compliqué bien sûr on
entendu les sirènes retentiront encore
une fois à cette nuit plusieurs fois
alors pendant la nuit aussi selon le
bureau du président du président
ukrainien zelensky et bien des missiles
ont été tirés contre kiev mais aussi
contre le l'aéroport de zito mire
interdiction de sortir donc depuis
samedi et les ukrainiens peuvent
désormais sortir un peu de chez eux pour
faire le minimum pour aller faire
quelques courses aller à la pharmacie
aller au supermarché mais les autorités
régionales de kiev les ont prévenus vous
n'allez pas reconnaître votre ville des
fortifications ont été a mises en place
ces dernières heures pour empêcher
l'arrivée des russes des habitants de
kiev donc qui ne vont pas forcément
reconnaître leur capital une capitale
qui a été frappé par des raids aériens
ces dernières heures ces derniers jours
une situation toujours forcément très
attendu à kiev mais les habitants
résistent